melissa is with us to kick off this hour
in san francisco
hi melissa how are you hi i'm doing well
how are you
better than i deserve what's up um
so i was just wondering how you
recommend
budgeting for people whose salary or
take-home pay is pre-dependent on
bonuses
okay how long have you been doing that
um i'm in my third year right now okay
you're single yeah and uh what do you
make
total so my base
right now is 95 000 and my bonus
just really depends on performance what
would you make last year
90. you made 90. i thought that was your
base
yeah that's my base and then my bonus
was 60 000.
okay so you made 150 000 last year yeah
what'd you make the year before total um
1 30. okay good so it's heading up then
that's good yeah i mean that means
you're performing well on this bonus
program good for you
okay well here's what um what i i've
lived on
straight commission or an irregular
income being self-employed my entire
life so i've never been able to do a
budget with a fixed
salaried income i've never been i mean i
teach people how to do it but i've never
done one
so what we have learned to do is a
prioritized
spending plan above what the known
money is now how often do you get these
bonuses
they're yearly once a year yeah okay
and so you're pretty much living on 90
and then this money comes in and you hit
the lottery
basically yeah so they just cut you a
sixty thousand dollar check one week
yeah yeah yeah that's a heck of a week
it's a whoo-hoo
week yeah i like it it's my favorite
week of the year
yeah okay so uh but so can and you can
run your household on 90 can't you
yeah i mean rent is super expensive
around here but
um but you're running your household on
90 aren't you
i am yeah but what i've noticed is a lot
of my co-workers they
basically go by the goal of spending all
of your base salary and then with the
bonus
they save that yeah well i don't agree
with that part but
uh but so but i think the budget is
fairly easy we can lay your budget out
on your salary and that's your monthly
budget
and basically go on every dollar or join
ramsey plus for a free trial and get
get the every dollar premium and that's
the world's best budgeting app it's a
very very robust
killer budgeting app to get help you
spend every dollar
of your 90 000 monthly on paper before
the month begins
in the app you're going to give every
dollar an assignment every dollar a name
now then what are we going to do with
the bonus well we're not going to
uh save that and blow everything else in
in your budget you save and operate your
household
then when you get extra money in your
case once a year you get this big budget
big bonus before the bonus comes i want
you to spend it
on paper also because a month before you
get it you know what it's going to be
don't you
so you know 30 days from now i'm gonna
get 60 grand right
yeah okay so i want you to get you can
just get a yellow pad out if you want
and say i'm gonna spend sixty thousand
dollars here on paper now by spending it
i mean
we have to allocate for taxes if they're
not taking taxes out
we have to we're going to put some in
savings uh we're going to be generous
with some of it be giving
uh we're going to uh spend some of it on
fun
we're going to pay some debt down we're
gonna hit some of the baby steps that
we've been wanting to hit
and some of these other things but every
dollar always
needs an assignment on any money before
it gets there
now if you don't know what the budget is
or let's say you're thinking about this
in september before you know what the
number is going to be in december
then you would start to just make a list
and say okay if i if i don't get as much
as i did last year
what's the most important thing i'm
going to do
and you prioritize the things on this
yellow pad from most important to least
important and you go as far
down that list as the money allows you
to go
when you run out of money on that list
it should be
that you've done the most important
things to you
before you did the least important
things to you because you had a
progressively important list a list that
is listed from most important least
important with a dollar amount beside it
how far down that list can i go and it
can be
i want to take a trip to europe and i
put a dollar amount beside it i want to
buy a car i put a dollar amount beside i
don't pay off this student loan i put a
dollar amount beside it
i want to finish up baby step 3 and have
an emergency fund of three to six months
expenses now put a dollar amount beside
it wherever you are whatever your goals
are now which one of those
is the most important is number one and
any money's left over can go to number
two
and any month left over can go to number
three and it's a prioritized
spending plan now for those of you that
get have an irregular income monthly
like for instance i grew up in the real
estate business and you really do not
necessarily know what you're going to
make next month
i mean you may have some closings in the
hopper you may have some contracts that
are coming at you but you
don't know exactly what you're going to
make next month so you really are going
to
live that list out in the coming 30 days
so rent electricity food it starts if
you're going from if you have zero that
you can count on if you're 100
commission like that situation yeah
you'd start with food
and then you'd do utilities and then you
do food shelter clothing transportation
and utilities you know
take care of those first and then we're
going to do baby steps and then we're
going to reduce that and then we're
going to do this and then we're going to
do that
um and you know we're not paying
property taxes before we buy food you
know we're going to decide
if i can only buy one thing what would i
buy and if i could only buy one more
thing what would i buy
and you list it out like that it makes
you really prioritize your life
the psychology of getting a 60 000 check
on a friday
man you could blow that and i like the
idea of being intentional before you're
holding that money yeah you got to do it
on paper before the money comes
because it's it's gone it's just those
of us that were in the real
real estate business or other straight
commission things you know we
you know we have you know we go from uh
you know
buying cadillacs to having them towed i
mean you know it's back and forth it's
all over this volatility
and uh you have this tendency in that
world not her
but if you're in that kind of a world a
sales world in particular
you have this tendency to think you can
out earn your stupidity
and i tried to out earn my stupidity for
years and i was a lot more stupid than i
was talented so
uh i couldn't do it and it kept catching
me and well even if you're not stupid
the world is is still spinning around
you there's always something that wants
your money somebody else might be stupid
and cause
yeah yeah there's always something
coming at you you can just count on it
it's
just part of the dad blame equation it's
how it works
so that's a great question great
question thank you for joining us we
appreciate you being a listener
good for you killing it melissa that's
fantastic yeah that's a wonderful income